ah
las comunidades autónomas han relajado
muchas restricciones tras el fin del
estado de alarma nacional este domingo
primero han levantado sus cierres
perimetrales aparte de las navidades los
españoles no habían podido salir de su
región desde que empezó el estado de
alarma en octubre se les impidió visitar
a sus familias en otras regiones
mientras que el país permanecía abierto
a los turistas extranjeros después
muchas comunidades han levantado el
toque de queda y ampliado los horarios
impuestos a la hostelería
por ejemplo en andalucía después de un
año de cierre han vuelto a abrir las
discotecas sin baile después de la
finalización del estado alarma muchos
españoles se han juntado para hacer la
fiesta en las grandes ciudades sin
respetar las distancias de seguridad y
sin ponerse la mascarilla las
autoridades temen un repunte de los
casos por lo cual piden a los ciudadanos
responsabilidad
[Música]
bélgica se prepara ya para la temporada
de verano con un des confinamiento
flexible con una vacunación que va a muy
buen ritmo las autoridades del país han
confirmado que a partir del 9 de junio
se podrá estar en el interior de bares y
de restaurantes se abren cines y teatros
eso sí con estrictas medidas de
seguridad y también se ampliará el
horario de las terrazas desde principios
de mayo se cierran hasta las 10 ahora
cambiará hasta las 11 y media de la
noche también volver a los festivales de
verano eso sí para asistir se tendrá que
tener un test negativo o bien confirmar
que uno ya ha sido vacunado el objetivo
es volver un poquito más a la normalidad
a medida que van bajando los contagios
pero también el número de enfermos en
los hospitales esto es especialmente
importante para la población del país
que ha vivido uno de los confinamientos
más duros de europa durante casi siete
meses apenas ha habido contactos
[Música]
a partir de este lunes 17 de mayo el
sector de la hospitalidad aquí en
inglaterra podrá por fin volver a abrir
sus puertas los packs y los restaurantes
podrán volver a atender clientes en
interiores se permitirá reuniones de
máximo 30 personas pero solo en
exteriores los teatros los museos y el
sector de las artes en general podrá
volver a tener público espectadores así
como los eventos deportivos pero no
todavía en su máxima capacidad uno de
los cambios más grandes es que se podrán
volver a tomar vacaciones en el exterior
el gobierno ha clasificado los países en
una lista semáforos sólo se permiten
hasta el momento 12 destinos de la lista
verde que ha causado controversia porque
se permite viajar a destinos territorios
contra mar británicos a los que es
imposible prácticamente llegar así como
países como australia que no permiten
turistas en este momento están además
portugal israel y singapur pero uno de
los grandes cambios y el que tal vez
produce más felicidad es que a partir de
la próxima semana se podrá volver a
abrazar
podrán abrazar especialmente ser
escritas
[Música]